[Music]
the release of Shazam is right around
the corner and early screenings have
been happening pretty much for the best
part of a year now recently a viewer who
has watched the entire film contacted me
on Twitter to go through their thoughts
on it and some of the key scenes and
plot details throughout this video I'll
be discussing major plot elements of the
movie so there will of course be heavy
spoilers this tweet is 100% legitimate
and the person has absolutely no reason
to lie and they've been correct on a lot
of aspects of the film that I've covered
in the past so yeah I really do trust
them in this I've deliberately hidden
their details by request as they signed
an NDA and I don't want them getting
into any trouble so with that out of the
way I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to okay so in the tweet when
talking about Shazam the view essays
that was actually really good totally
different tone than any other DC movie
it was very funny I laughed a lot the
villain is Mark Strong and he's good but
a little run-of-the-mill he wasn't
worthy to be Shazam as a kid so he's now
on the hunt for who is that's probably
the weakest point Billy Batson and the
rest of the adopted kids kill it and are
an absolute highlight belli figuring out
his powers is an awesome sequence
there's great references to the universe
and it's clearly a DC hue movie a
Batarang is involved and in neck-down
show of Superman is in what I think is
the post-credits scene when asked if
this was the best DC movie so far they
said no hard to judge completely with
the kreisau Man of Steel is still my
number 1 it's better than Suicide Squad
though absolutely I'm still to this day
undecided on Batman V Superman it's on
par with Wonder Woman and probably
better as a movie than Justice League so
this is pretty good news especially for
people like me who've been let down by
the
see movies in the past in regards to the
Superman shot it appears that this is
just a stand-in and DC may have just
inserted this to show their plans
obviously with news of Henry Cavill
departure now up in the air we will see
upon release whether this happens or not
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this reaction and if you're excited
for the movie make sure you comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my fan theory on whether Tony Stark
is alive in spider-man far from home
which would be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thanks again
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition that you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]